[Applause]
workout is done what we can do today is
the team tells me we got some questions
there
on youtube so what they did is they went
through all of them these are gillian of
them
and they picked the top five most asked
questions on there
so we're gonna end the workout today
answering a few of your questions
chappelle has him what do you got mr
lacey
all right this is from rachel jones
underscore 94.
biggest pet peeve in the gym
biggest pet peeve one of mine i know
it's irrational but when people ask me
how many sets i got because if somebody
if i'm waiting for something i'll just
wait and and perv on you from afar until
you're done
so now i go you want to work in with me
instead of like if somebody asked me
i'll either go i have a million or 100
or something like irrational answers oh
all right
he doesn't do that i'm just gonna do
this and then like
i'm like no seriously i have a hundred
so i just creep but now i say work in
with me
but also people who don't react to rape
they'll leave like weird
yeah i would say that's right number one
it's like you're in the middle of the
straight up set
yeah i'd be like yo dude so this weekend
like oh hey
oh we're gonna do a podcast in the
middle of the set now that's what we're
doing
i'd say that it used to be guys who took
their shirts off in the gym but then i
came here i was like
okay okay thank you you guys can do it
you work hard enough you burn that right
yeah yes that's it what else you got
uh this is from nate rivie
19. least favorite workout
oh my least favorite i get nervous if
it's like a big uh deadlift day yeah
yeah i think if you're really pushing it
on there's a reason that people skip leg
day it's because it's [ __ ]
uncomfortable
like we
it's [ __ ] painful you don't want to
finish it there's nothing worse than a
guy that skips like that
right you can't skip like that for all
the haters out there
i think we skipped like that yeah
brandon skips like that he can he can
dead lift 600 pounds okay
yeah yeah logic um also
you know i low-key kind of hate working
biceps
because it just hurts i don't like like
especially after a back day your biceps
blown out super set like
and you're doing shoulders and bye yeah
halfway through the middle
like something like that i know you feel
like you're already feeling when you
yeah
it's just i think it's a smaller muscle
it cramps up more so ironically even
though a lot of people love to do arms i
kind of get most of my bicep work
through
heavy back work so i don't spend a lot
of time doing it it's just i can power
through that stuff cardio because now
before you guys get out you do like 34
minutes
if you don't feel like doing cardio that
[ __ ] sucks yeah because it's boring
so you got to find a way to hack it
that's some podcast
yeah oh that's yeah that is my least
favorite cardio
i don't [ __ ] with that oh you know what
i did i was in north carolina and i did
a swimming workout yesterday it reminded
me of my competitive swim days
i was in the pool doing like two laps at
a time and i'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] isn't
comfortable so shout out to all the
swimmers
i think that's the hardest most
uncomfortable workout to really push
yourself in a swimming pool
you can't breathe no i just pulled the
back and i didn't have a goggle so my
eyes got all [ __ ] up
it's a great workout but it's so in the
middle of it you're like i just i would
rather die to be honest
i would rather just kill myself all
right this is from
d butcher 30. if you could only wear
one shoe for the rest of your life what
pair would it be
you know marshall rocket knows no no
no no no goals no hoes
yeah you'll notice one of the guys
coming home those are cool
are they flat on the bottom
one shoe it'd be between two not those
uh it'd be between
two it would be either the
nike uh sp dunk strange love those are
my favorite
shoe i own i wear them all the time or
the uh
jordan one union the la edition
be one of those two uh vans you know
all your kids at all my kicks fans i
don't even know even though i have all
these nice ass jordans
um this is from
tj 303 roach what is the best way to put
on weight
having insanely high metabolism
we put height high metabolism human high
okay high metabolism let me
start with that because i think
metabolism tends to be overrated like
as far as if you were to measure
somebody's actual metabolism individual
variances between people's metabolism
isn't as big as you think
your real problem is probably that you
don't eat it so if you were to actually
track your calories
if you're 150 pounds and you eat 4000
calories a day
like and you're not getting weight
you're lying maybe you know it's just a
matter of when i talk to guys who are
more ectomorphic or skinny or whatever
leaner
it's usually just a matter of i go
really track yourself are you eating
that
one gram 1.5 grams protein a day and
usually that they struggle with the
eating
so if you're truly eating the enough
calories you will grow it's just you
have to ultimately
force feed yourself and track it and
keep it down eat enough carbs and
protein yeah that's a job in itself
yeah i would say dana weights worse than
losing weight that's why it's like
eating nonstop yeah if you're not yeah
if that's not enough
because you can there's there's a lot of
things you can do to like
curb your appetite you know like you
know nicotine or different things that
are like
you know exactly
that's a great one to stimulate an
appetite is a little bit harder there's
fewer options
and when you don't feel like eating you
gotta yeah yeah shakes
yeah so is that it i think
uh yeah we have one more one more last
one this is from
jack barton 23 what's up uh
what supplements brand wise and
ingredient-wise
do you recommend um testosterone
and oh shuffle um
i don't think there's too many
supplements that are really worth the
money that you're gonna pay besides
protein
creatine and maybe a couple others like
glutamine or zma or something like
but there's so many supplements on the
market i'm like okay before we spend 200
a month on these other unproven
supplements
are you eating your body weight in
protein
have you tried creatine does that work
for you so if you're not doing those two
things and getting enough sleep all the
supplements in the world
even steroids aren't going to work if
you're not getting enough protein sleep
and basic nutrition bro unless you're
ready to raid the capital
do not take that psycho pre-workout
one other little hack people ask me
about my workouts i've tried a lot of
different pre-workouts you know
essentially the heavy lifters and
pre-workouts are caffeine i use green
tea pills
it's a really cheap thing you can get
green tea extract pills from
costco yeah you can like it's
concentrates you can look
if the servings one or two let's take
six yeah but it's still cheaper it's
like still like a buck a serving or
whatever
um so it is you know caffeine
creatine protein that's 90 of what
you're probably doing in the gym
that's it man that's it that's it good
questions we'll do this again sometime
soon you guys stay fit